okay I got one point I won the first one
and it beat me four in a row okay this I
had success with that the other day I
had success here
I got a King side attack I ended up
losing but maybe they'll play into that
same line I think this is one of the
lines where I had a beat I had such a
locked position same stuff happened hmm
believe I get these guys rolling now let
me do this stop be for advance make that
more difficult to get in I get these
pawns rolling I get my pawn up to g4 I'm
pretty sure it did that move as well so
it is playing the same line as before
it's threatening this to get this
advancing because my rook is unprotected
so Bishop d7 or e 6 I like this
maybe rook here if Queen there okay now
it's kind of making silly moves although
pawn push might be on the cards hmm
about b6 let's try that
b6 let's get this pawn going g 4 h 5 h
4e SATA I think these are nonsensical
moves yeah it's it's not it's not
knowing what to do here I think I keep
pushing this is kind of what happened
before but I wasn't able to convert it
oh but I could actually take that I'm
constrained I have to defend this pawn
if I play rook here okay my nighties
defending there's still no b4 I think I
just play here first my rook is
incredibly passive but I'll give that a
try so my queen could just recapture
caused me problems though it's not gonna
make me and make it easy
nope it's not gonna be easy I think I
gotta get that pun I have to get that
pun ok pawn takes
let's take here my pawn push I want to
keep this diagonal and file closed
computer is a monster a monster when
there's a bunch of open files and stuff
so I still have time down upon still and
now we have that doing okay well let me
get over here this pond I'll just maybe
hide behind it can I make that work the
bishops pinned can I get my rook working
here you see this is where the computers
are relentless oh yeah
how am I supposed to see that in these
blitz games oh man look at this this
this Queen is just gonna be a giant
beast look I mean can she hit any more
pieces rook takes Knight Queen takes
pawn Knight Bishop Bishop rook rook pawn
nothing nothing
nope nope nope hang on did it see that
move is this a resource oh wait a second
wait I'm on the climb on that rook it's
still gonna get the material there's
this a blunder at Nick camp and it does
a blunder time my bishop whoa wait a
second am i defending stuff now oh man
oh this is dangerous
it does make mistakes that was a Miss
feels like it was a mistake
just give me that night you take my
night oh it's on the ropes now
it's afraid huh where are you going
where are you going now Oh
oh man what I want to do I only have a
minute ten I'm up a piece I'm up a rook
I'm up a rock ha ha ha Brooke how did
that happen what's the win here that's
why I take stuff
can I take here I think that works kind
of I get a rook here move oh you just
take what your queen ha ha hang on hang
on I'm not giving up yet oh I might be
giving up I don't I [ __ ] up they are on
my bishop mmm go back here
does this move work with bishop here ah
I don't have any time ah I don't have
any time these are it's so difficult I
don't have anything would they go for a
perpetual now that's not really working
oh this is I'm not I don't have any
material I ran out of fuel the last
track of material Oh was I up a full
Brooke at one point not a full ruck I
mean there were a bunch of pawns that it
had ah there's no way night before I was
just stunned I figured night takes c7 I
was beat I started to believe this thing
I can't I came not gonna believe it
anymore
night before I take the rook it has a
couple pawns three pawns
oh I can't believe that was silly